you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chess calm
and I just got paired up playing a five
oh game against Phoenix 40 109 alright
so I'm just going to reinforce d5 here
and try some something simple like
getting this Bishop out side of the pawn
chain I do run the risk of some quick
pressure against a b7 or even that move
okay let's play Bishop to e6 preparing
to recapture with the bishop and get rid
of the light square bishop this would be
desirable as soon as g3 is played this
is probably the most important minor
piece for white to hang on to without
him around got some King side weaknesses
which is the likely direction for the
White King and I take c4 and get away
with it hang on to the pawn not so sure
about that
I could challenge the knight as well I
think I prefer doing this I may still
capture it and then at least my knight
will be able to reinforce the c-4 pawn
if I do make this capture I will
certainly be trying to hang on to it
so I don't want to just give up this
Center pond and allow white to freely
regain it an inconvenient way so I think
this is the best way to go about the
bishops development I am obstructing my
epon but I do have some pressure on the
center let's just play Bishop g7
you know this might be a move soon okay
that seems a little bit awkward
definitely recapture with the Queen she
wasn't doing anything all right so with
this structural shift I need to get the
e5 pawn break in
I could head right for Bishop to h3 and
even consider let's go for this even
consider some kind of an attack white
should not capture the bishop because I
could help with Knight to g4 I probably
have to take route to be one our rifted
ba can be chased away with Bishop f4 so
let's just get development complete
white would like to play b4 b5 so I
think this Queen is misplaced would not
be surprised if she moves soon I could
look for a5 but
I see no reason to do that let's just
get on with playing e5
yeah with this uh okay now maybe now
maybe I could do this is why really
going to be able to take advantage of
the b6 square hmm I can actually be
quite tricky hmm okay let's
consider here
I can also just move the knife first so
I would be striking at this pawn hmm let
me do this first
I'd much rather make this move if I know
that the knight cannot try to make use
of the b6 square I think in an ideal
world I'd like to get an a6 and somehow
get the night right here on b5 because
he he blocks any pressure along the B
file I think I just have to take now all
right so this pawn I see more as a
liability than anything but I am winning
the d4 upon am I not and maybe even the
c5 I'm not sure what I'm missing
scooping up the D pawn so very odd
that's a blunder I could take on c5 with
a fork
my only concern well I just take here
first address the threat so this is
completely winning though let me just
double check I have an unprotected queen
there isn't anything fancy with getting
out of the fork could just take the
night and then take on c5 I don't see
anything better yeah
just miss cow I think they had a
complete blind spot to that d4 pawn
that was a quick game mmm let's go back
into it because I think oh I don't know
I'm not sure exactly what I would do
let me flip the board I'm not sure what
exactly I would do in this position
right here if they just addressed this
threat on d4 because this is this is a
bit awkward and I don't know that I
would want to take because I'm pretty
sure white would recapture reinforce
this point and now it makes this strike
not as you know white has clear control
over d4 in the event of a capture one
day let's just make it nothing move in
the event of a capture this is no no
problem at all this is a really strong
structure so my point here is that I
don't think I'm ever really threatening
to capture the night so on III I guess I
could look forward to e5 and you know
what here's another thing maybe I could
maybe I could play a six here
yeah maybe I could play a six here and
work around this night on b6 my concern
during the game was that both the bishop
and Knight can cause my queen some
problems if I did the a6 move we should
just go back right around here right now
and you know maybe I should have played
85 all together just to stop any of this
idea with a 5 and then that kind of
stuff but if I'm playing a 6 right now
instead of the knight move this is an
issue I'm pretty sure because we have
the knight coming in here and the bishop
here and there's just a nice hmm
how to say nice control over both color
complexes the night on b6 controls a lot
of light the bishop will be their
control dark and it felt like my queen
would have some trouble you know what do
I do about this fork for starters I'm
going here I'm running into the tempo
gain move Bishop f4 if I go here I don't
know what I want to do is have my knight
here to offset this guy but it's it's
tough to manage because I always have to
be concerned about my b7 pawn as well
Queen putting pressure on it so if I do
this maybe I don't know here here
there's this move and my queen is
trapped I have to do this so it was
awkward to say the least maybe there is
some little tight rope that I could work
but in a blitz format little time here I
I thought it was just too much to have
both the knight and Bishop breathing
down at these Queen side squares as far
as the opening I wonder if you know I
think that this is fine I did it there
there's even some say instead of the
knight move if capture oh ok on the
capture I could just go for this give up
the bishop pair and then play with this
structure very quiet position and
I think it's perfectly fine even his
position but we had this line here with
Bishop e6 and I think there is a
variation that runs captures Bishop
takes and then white avoids this
exchange and then white plays c5 now
preparing to meet Knight c3 with Bishop
c6 and then goes about completing
development with Knight to d7 and oh not
just get some natural moves in there
something like this would follow yeah
it's not a direction we went in I was a
bit surprised in the game to see Knight
takes Knight I don't think the computer
would be a fan of that I could have also
may be considered capturing on c4 but
holding the strong point is is fine I'm
pretty sure could I could have
considered but on this capture you can
be sure white would play in the center
and then maybe I have some concern about
my bishops position after Knight takes
maybe there's a push and he's running
short on squares somehow it's not a full
full pawn advantage I wouldn't think if
I'm going for this capture so I just
went with completing development and
important to note is that inviting the
Queen here not a good idea because now
there's mating ideas much rather work
around a bishop on the h3 Square
maintain the tension is white as best
instead of inviting most powerful piece
into your position and also the knight
as a result
so queen v3 yeah I don't know III think
queen bee 3 was probably wrong white
should get on with B 4 and go for this
I'm pretty sure this is the correct plan
and meanwhile I'm looking for an e5
break and eventually there'll be some
target white will create on the Queen
side I don't know just playing out some
moves here not sure where to go with the
bishop let's just say f4 yeah it seems
pretty sensible to combat my ID of the
e5 break mmm
at the same time maybe it's running into
this move and now my bishops there to
support I'm not sure where the dark
square bishop belongs but definitely
pawn pawn break wise white should be
going for this a 4 B 4 a 4 B 5 and yeah
it's it's a tough call I'm not sure
maybe maybe white doesn't have to
declare the bishop just yet it doesn't
have to devout develop the bishop and he
gets some pawn moves in you know I think
the B 3 square is good for the Queen but
with the b-pawn rolling first you know
not sure okay
well we'll have to double-check it with
the engine and see what we can take away
from it okay stockfish let us see it
likes black already doesn't it doesn't
like g3 computer is being silly it's
perfectly fine
okay and the approach I take is fine as
well as mentioned just to quickly recap
this on takes there's captures captures
and then the recapture if this capture
is played in black immediately
recaptures there's possibilities 495 and
also Queen to b3 and these light squares
on the Queen side can be a little bit
difficult to defend the computer will
have no problems but the these these
type of things come
to mind this pressure against a b7 quite
avoiding the night for Bishop exchange
in the game it was an immediate 95 it
should be 6
I immediately challenged the night I
don't think I'm ever really threatening
to capture the night cuz white is able
to recapture in my f6 Knight needs to
find a new square just castles wants to
go in for the capture anything wrong
with g6 yeah doesn't like g6 so I guess
I should be capturing here and then it
wants to go with Knight to f3
hmm there's a very odd sequence meeting
captures with Knight to f3 not the most
natural move in the world huh I mean on
the white end I'd be looking at this
kind of stuff okay I am preparing to
enter an ending okay so this has this as
a threat so that just helped just
playing around with the position a
little bit let me know what the purpose
of Knight f3 was it's to avoid the
knight exchange to avoid the Queen
exchange after this capture on c4 Black
is threatening to take the knight and
then take the Queen uh-huh so Knight to
f3 and then Oh
this also has another idea in mind
Knight to g5 and that's interesting okay
so my idea to play g6 wasn't the
greatest how can white have better
followed up here let's see Knight c3
wants to capture and then Knight takes
Bishop takes hmm I think in the game I
would have captured with no III probably
go with the bishop yeah
just offering a light square Bishop
exchange and I wonder if Knight f3 here
I could still go with c5 now it seems a
bit off yeah I may have to allow a
knight for Bishop exchange here yeah
this wouldn't be a problem pretty uh I
don't know seven pounds each the bishops
I don't know how great they are it says
the static structure in the center
pretty level evaluation but takes pawn
takes here
it's not really a big fan of that
because this is awkward notice the
pressure against d5 I want to eventually
move my bishop he's
I don't know he's not he's a strictly
defensive piece so I'd like to move him
away but it's a little bit tricky to do
that and the night on b6 he isn't the
greatest defender in the world he could
always be challenged with this a pawn
yeah I'm trying to stop and that type of
in advance you know in cases where the
knight is on B six in a four a five the
only way to stop that is with a five I'm
creating weaknesses like to be five
comes to mind anyhow
we didn't have that I just went with a
Fenian kiddo
yeah it doesn't like this I was really
happy to see this because this is the
most an invasive piece to me whites
night in my position so I'm just
recapturing and happily developing
another piece but they had they had in
mind to shut down the structure like
this and the computer really isn't such
a fan I went immediately for Bishop h3 I
just wanted to be assured that the
LightScribe bishops are exchanged
I could Castle here but maybe this in on
Bishop h3 this guy's preserved I'm not
so sure yeah this might be a bit too too
much of an inconvenience for white we
could see this position opening up and
it may turn out that white returns here
just so that the king could feel a
little bit more secure because I am
doing what I am taking away as it stands
right now this flight square for white
the g2 square so I could have gone with
castles is what I'm getting at instead
of Bishop h3 right away I shouldn't have
some fear of white avoiding a light
square bishop exchange but I went in for
it right away
captures something natural this is what
my instinct told me to just play a 5 but
we have to Yates and 85 months ago with
E 5 and another suggestion it is
pointing out that a6 is a move here
maybe I was just seeing things like
likes a5 right away anything wrong with
who have I played something Knight takes
well it's not that it's not the best
Bishop to e3 pretty level
I'm not sure we could really trust this
evaluation so much I'd say it's still
pretty even I'm sure some weight is
being given to these guys here being so
close
white having some space on the queenside
but you know I should be able to hold my
ground here yeah you could see something
like e six and then offer a queen
exchange and I'd be trying for a good
versus bad bishop thing you know I have
the better coordination between my
structure and remaining bishop but you
know they didn't capture they just
blundered here well not at this exact
point but I capture first and then
grabbing upon and they should just take
my knight here it's still even --is--
even though I'd be up upon oh you know
what I think maybe on Knight takes pawn
takes there's Queen c4 yeah that is one
of the moves also over to d1 ooh I
didn't even I didn't see this I have a
way out with Queen to c8 I didn't
calculate any of that though yeah I
didn't see that as a possibility Knight
takes for some odd reason this position
is I'm reminded of having a similar
position before or a similar type of
tactic Knight takes pawn takes and then
there's pin and my way out is to have a
counter-attack against the rook didn't
see any of that
neither did my opponent and this was a
big a big blunder here short end to this
game just get to take the knight and
then after the recapture I get another
pawn and the exchange might have follow
something like this this Bishop isn't
really doing anything kept still playing
the center to be a little bit careful of
the dark squares but I'm I'll try to
kill this Bishop with an f6 and E 5
structure I would weaken my my 7th rank
if I do this I could even go with rook
to b5 first not even letting the bishop
step foot here you know but if the one
day the bishop does get on this diagonal
I always have this type of structure in
mind just to highlight this right here
and I'll just have to cover my 7th rank
from the Queen and rook which shouldn't
be a problem because I have two rips to
there one okay
well anyhow short game number wise
number move wise but hope there's still
some things to take away from that
opening and middle game as usual feel
free to leave in the feedback in the
comments section below and I hope you
got something out of it that's all for
now take care bye
you